un círculo está centrado en el punto b
entonces aquí podemos ver nuestro
círculo aquí se encuentra nuestro punto
b que justamente está en el centro nos
dice los puntos a c y d están en su
circunferencia entonces podemos ver a c
y de estos tres puntos en efecto están
en la circunferencia ahora si el ángulo
a de c a d se mide 45 grados cuánto mide
el ángulo
abc a b c muy bien entonces vamos a
tratar de pensar cómo es que estos dos
ángulos están relacionados y podemos
observar que el ángulo adc el ángulo a
de c es un ángulo inscrito verdad
en cambio el ángulo abc es un ángulo
central verdad y ambos sostienen a este
arco que tenemos aquí el arco hace
entonces nosotros sabemos por el teorema
del ángulo inscrito que un ángulo
inscrito
adc será digamos que sostiene el mismo
arco que quede que un ángulo central
entonces tendrá la mitad de la medida de
este ángulo verdad es decir el ángulo
central tendría que ser el doble del
ángulo inscrito pero si el ángulo
inscrito que es el adc mide 45 grados
quiere decir que el ángulo abc es el
doble es decir tiene que ser 90 grados
muy bien entonces vamos a comprobar
nuestra respuesta y es correcto